mais je peux m'en et la neige et le
soleil
j'ai eu la chance comme m
s'il vomit je vais me ranger
le métier ce que tu fais tu as par des
gardes et café présentes à comprendre
six armes et des cafés travailleurs au
starbucks tu vois ce que je veux dire
ice watch ministre
il faut attendre un pitch la
dynastie hô chi minh de
reconditionner pouvoir
ah oui
les jambes je les aime pendant deux
heures et puis après ça lui
qui nous tenir
ghz
[Musique]
je suis minute
du asking me to be made for just to
reach out et aux objectifs
de par
sa fonction
tu trouves que les conditions sont
bonnes si on ne fait rien ça va être de
pire en pire pour l'avenir pour l'avenir
je sais même pas si je vais dire honte
de moi
[Musique]
inside me